sometimes people don't want to hear the
truth
because they don't want their illusions
destroyed
that which does not kill us
makes us stronger
i'm not upset that you lied to me
i'm upset that from now on
i can't believe you
a woman brightens up facial flaws with
cosmetics
figure flaws with clothes
and mental flaws with marriage to a
smart man
he who has a why
to live for
can bear almost any how
the true man wants two things
danger and play
for that reason he wants women
as the most dangerous plaything
the lonely one offers his hand too
quickly to whomever he encounters
hope in reality is the worst of all
evils
because it prolongs the torments of man
the snake which cannot cast its skin has
to die
as well the minds which are prevented
from changing their opinions
they cease to be mined
to feel good in a marriage means to feel
good with your spouse's shortcomings
no one can construct for you the bridge
upon which precisely you must cross the
stream of life
no one
but yourself alone
the unselective knowledge drive
resembles the indiscriminate sexual
drive
signs of vulgarity
virtue is the health of the soul
you have your way
i have my way
as for the right way the correct way
and the only way
it does not exist
the surest way to corrupt a youth is to
instruct him to hold in higher esteem
those who think alike
than those who think differently
ultimately
it is the desire not the desired that we
love
perhaps i know best
why it is man alone who laughs
he alone suffers so deeply that he had
to invent laughter
he that feeds the hungry refreshes his
own soul
says wisdom
a thought
even a possibility
can shatter and transform us
to live is to suffer to survive is to
find some meaning in the suffering
those who inflate themselves are cursed
when pricked by a small pin to burst
it is nobler to declare oneself wrong
than to insist on being right
especially when one is right
whoever is not capable of either love or
friendship he most certainly makes his
bet on marriage
you must be ready to burn yourself in
your own flame
how could you rise anew if you have not
first become ashes
is life not a thousand times too short
for us
to bore ourselves
he who fights monsters
might take care
lest he thereby become a monster
must pay dearly for immortality
one has to die several times while still
alive
the lack of young men
is that they think they are more happy
or unhappy
than they really are
i was in darkness
but i took three steps and found myself
in paradise
the first step was a good thought
the second
a good word
and the third
a good deed
the higher man
is distinguished from the lower by his
fearlessness
and his readiness to challenge
misfortune
the strength of a person's spirit
would then be measured by how much truth
he could tolerate
or more precisely
to what extent he needs to have it
deluded
disguised sweetened muted
falsified
the most spiritual people experience by
far the most painful tragedies
but this is precisely why they honor
life
because it provides them with their
greatest adversities
he who cannot put his thoughts on ice
should not enter into the heat of
dispute
many are stubborn in pursuit of the path
they have chosen
few in pursuit of the
goal i cannot believe in a god who wants
to be praised all the time
we stop too often at knowing the good
without doing it
because we also know the better but
cannot do it
sensuality often forces the growth of
love too much
so that its roots remains weak and is
easily torn up
he who obeys
does not listen to himself
he who cannot obey himself will be
commanded
that is the nature of living creatures
without music
life would be an error
what was silent in the father speaks in
the sun
and often i found in the sun the
unveiled secret of the father
the fewer friends a person has
the more he has the time to be alone
with himself
and the happier they feel
in the mountains the shortest way is
from peak to peak
but for that root
thou must have long legs
proverbs should be peaks
and those spoken to
should be big and tall
i noticed that autumn
is more the season of the soul than of
nature when we have to change our mind
about a person
we hold the inconvenience he causes us
very much against him
it's risky to get married after 40
because the risk of making such a
decision under the influence of
loneliness is very high
the secret of reaping the greatest
fruitfulness
and the greatest enjoyment from life
is to live
dangerously
be very careful if you are praised
it means that you can only be sure that
you are not on your true path yet
but on someone else's
to become what one is
one must not have the faintest notion
what one is
i know of no better life purpose than to
perish in attempting the great
and the impossible
to some people
you may give not your hand but only a
slap with the paw
and i would at your paw
might also have claws
the only thing that makes a marriage
unhappy
is not a lack of love
it's the lack of friendship
to speak about oneself not at all is a
very refined form of hypocrisy
under peaceful conditions
the militant man attacks himself
[Music]
is not wounded vanity the mother of all
tragedies
and when you gaze long enough into the
abyss
the abyss
will gaze back
into you
the advantage of a bad memory
is that one enjoys several times the
same good things
for the first time
what is great in humans
is that it is a bridge and not a goal
what can be loved in humans is that
it is a going over
and going under
you